(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
- Do you mind if I tag into
the journaling conversation
you're having?
- Yes. Do you journal?
- I do.
I say this and especially you
just played a clip from it,
but I find if you write down
every few nights what you're saddest about
or angriest about, you can start
to see your own life as a story.
And when you see your own life as a story,
sometimes you can zoom out
and encourage the main character
to make better decisions.
- Wow.
(audience clapping)
- I find, I always-
- I love how you just worded that.
Also, it's probably
great material for you.
- Well, it's true.
- All your saddest stuff.
- It's honestly like,
it's the basis of, like,
so much of "The Old Man
and the Pool" is like,
- Yeah.
- Finding the humor
in the things that are the hardest.
- Yeah.
- Because I feel
like that's sort of like, I don't know.
I think that's the coping
mechanism of comedy.
- Yeah. Which is a...
It's a good coping mechanism.
- (chuckles) It's not bad.
- Yes.
So, I heard that you
didn't initially want kids,
right, in life?
I didn't either initially.
- Yeah.
- I was reluctant my... (chuckles)
- I wrote,
my last special was called "The New One,"
and it was all about how I
never want to have a child
and all the reasons why
and how I had a child
and how I was right.
(all laughing)
And then, ultimately, how I was wrong.
And that's why it's emotional.
And, you know, these
shows I always try to,
I've done about five of these
solo shows and yeah, that's me
and my daughter at "The
Old Man and the Pool."
- Oh, that's so cool.
- Yeah.
That was at Lincoln Center.
- Look at you now.
- Ah, yeah.
- I know.
Then you pumped them out
and you're like, "Wait a
minute, you're fantastic."
Yeah.
- No,
she's completely the best.
But I always was like,
you know, the first,
I would say like, the
first year was really hard
and that's when I wrote
that show.
- Yeah.
- It was just like this
period where I was,
like I felt as the dad.
Like, I was like nothing.
You know, like I was the
intern of the family.
Like, I was this pudgy
milkless vice president
of the family.
Huge title, no power,
also oversees Congress.
And I was just like, this is so hard.
And then, but now, she's eight
and she's just the greatest.
And I, it's...
I mean, it's amazing.
- You're gonna have another special
about when she's a teenager. (chuckles)
- Oh yeah.
No, I mean, I...
My brain goes to when she's 16,
'cause she's eight now, but
my brain goes to when she's 16
and she's gonna be like,
"My dad is garbage."
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- And it'll happen.
Like that's natural.
That's what development is.
But like my, you know, my dad
didn't have to deal with that.
Like it was the '80s, no
one listened to children.
(all laughing)
Like we said it, but he was
like, "Is someone talking?"
You know what I mean?
- Sure.
- And that's how I ended
up being a comedian.
But the...
(all laughing)
- Childhood trauma.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- For the win.
- But like,
when she's 16, she'll be
like, "My dad is garbage."
And I'm gonna be like, "She's so right."
(all laughing)
How can I amplify her
voice? She's so brave.
You know what I mean?
- (laughs) How can I amplify her voice?
- She's the great, I mean...
I'm so lucky.
She's the greatest.
- Oh, my God.
You are so funny.
- Oh.
- Oh, you've covered
so many areas already.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Okay, so wait.
Your Broadway show,
you're talking about "The
Old Man and the Pool."
- Yes.
- And now,
you made the jump to Netflix.
You were so successful that they...
You now are on Netflix.
- It's now on Netflix.
- That's amazing. Yeah.
It's a...
I'm so excited for two reasons.
One is that it, you know,
the show is about death and mortality.
And I set out like four
years ago to write this show.
That's all essentially like jokes
and stories about life and
death and losing people
and how hard that is
and how can we make
people laugh from that.
Like, can I do that?
And so I had this fear when I did it,
like, "Oh no, like what if
this is really hard for people
to hear who are going
through losing people and all that stuff?"
And actually it was the opposite.
- Yeah.
It was this thing
where people would come up to
me after shows and be like,
you know, "I lost my dad.
I lost someone in my family recently
and that's what I needed
to hear right now.
Like, I needed to laugh.
It was hard for me
to laugh for a long time."
- Yeah.
- So that was cool.
- The connection of that. Yeah.
- And then the other side of it is like,
and I was gonna ask you folks, this is...
I talked about this in the show.
We weren't an I love
you family growing up.
Like we don't say I love you.
Like, in our family we say, "Take care,"
which is not the same,
- Which is kind of like,
which is kind of like
what the person says at the grocery store.
Like when you see them
and like, "So take care."
- It's a very grocery store,
bank teller kind of thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it's kind of a
passive-aggressive command.
Like-
- It's a little removed.
- Yeah, like, I'm gonna need you
to do something for me, take care.
You know what I mean?
(all laughing)
And did you or were you
I love you families?
- We were, and I mean, and we are.
- Oh, that's sweet.
- I mean, I say it many,
many times to my kids a day.
- Oh, no, no.
- It's in Illinois.
- I do it to my daughter.
Oh, yeah, sure.
I'm saying-
- I was gonna say-
- I'm saying with my folks. (chuckles)
- Yeah. They were, they were little.
- That's sweet.
- Yeah.
- You know, the thing was, yeah,
like, it was weird because I, you know,
I'd be dodging, you know,
I'd be dodging smacks
across the head one moment.
- Yeah.
- And then,
I love you would come as,
"Do you?"
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- Then you're like,
- So it was a little,
- And then you're like,
- It was a little.
- You were-
- You know-
- For the next 20 years, you work on
what the definition of love is.
- Yeah.
Plausible deniability after that.
- Yeah, bro.
- That's incredible.
That's any kid in the south.
(all laughing)
Let's do another commercial break.
Mike's latest standup special is called
"The Old Man and the Pool."
You can see it on Netflix
starting November 21st.